Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje
eu quero falar sobre um assunto que me
preocupa muito sobre uma das vitaminas
mais importantes para o funcionamento do
organismo eu tenho visto muitas pessoas
no meu consultório com níveis baixos de
vitamina B12 e muitos pacientes até
passaram por outros profissionais que
ignoraram esses baixos níveis nos exames
justamente por estarem dentro da
referência do laboratório mesmo que os
exames mostrem uma faixa considerada
normal se estiver no limite inferior
desta
normalidade Você pode ter problemas
neurológicos depressão perda de memória
e até sintomas que podem ser confundidos
com demência mas que na verdade são
causados por baixos níveis dessa
vitamina tão importante vamos entender
melhor quando você olha o seu exame de
B12 existe uma faixa de referência de
resultado que normalmente vai de 200 a
900 PG por ml é uma variação bem grande
não é mas atenção um nível de B2 de 200
ou mesmo 300 PG por ml já é uma
deficiência importante já é preocupante
pessoal isso porque mesmo que esteja
dentro dessa referência existe algo bem
complicado essa referência geralmente é
baseada em estatísticas de pessoas que
fizeram esse exame o problema é que
muitas dessas pessoas podem estar
doentes Pois existe uma epidemia de B12
baixa então não queremos nos basear
nessas estatísticas porque elas incluem
muitas pessoas com saúde
comprometida queremos um resultado de
exame que reflita a saúde ideal e
otimizada então manter a B12 numa faixa
de 200 ou 300 no exame de sangue não é
nada bom especialmente para sua saúde
cerebral e o que que seria um valor
erado do bom de B12 no exame eu diria
que uma faixa ideal está no mínimo acima
de 500 pgr por ml estudos sugerem que
valores realmente Seguros devem estar
acima de 500 para a maioria das pessoas
na prática às vezes só conseguimos
ajustar bem esses níveis de B12 e ver
melhorias significativas na saúde quando
os níveis estão ainda mais altos acima
de 600 ou até 800 isso é algo muito
individual e que o profissional de saúde
deve avaliar com cuidado com esses
níveis muitos baixos de vitamina B12
Você pode ter vários sintomas esses
sintomas estão Associados à fadiga falta
de energia falta de ar perda de Paladar
e olfato formigamento nas extremidades
como nas mãos e pés e até uma língua
vermelha inchada podem todos ser sinais
de deficiência Além disso feridas na
boca visão embaçada ou dupla tontura são
sintomas comuns a deficiência de B12
também está associada a muitos outros
sintomas inclusive neurológicos e
psicológicos por exemplo a relação entre
a deficiência de B12 e enxaqueca é bem
documentada e mesmo depressão e perda de
memória a ansiedade também pode ser
agravada pela falta dessa vitamina além
disso a deficiência de B12 pode imitar
sintomas de doenças neurológicas graves
pode-se parecer com esclerose múltipla
Doença de Alzheimer e até autismo a
falta de B12 aumenta a inflamação no
corpo estresse oxidativo e com isso ela
aumenta os níveis de um aminoácido
chamado homocisteína não sei se vocês já
fizeram esse exame homocisteína mas é um
exame muito importante que eu sempre
peço PR os meus pacientes quando esse
marcador homocisteína está elevado no
sangue está associado a riscos
aumentados de doenças cardiovasculares e
também a diminuição da resposta do
defesa a resposta monológica as
vitaminas B6 B9 e B12 ajudam a decompor
a homocisteína reduzindo seus níveis e
minimizando o risco de doenças cardíacas
muitas vezes para manter esses níveis de
homocisteína que são os ideais por volta
de 6 a 8 no exame o paciente pode
precisar de níveis mais altos de B12 em
conjunto com níveis bons de B9 ou folato
isso porque a B12 ajuda na metabolização
do folato também ajuda na digestão e
metabolização de gorduras e carboidratos
na absorção de ferro na saúde
reprodutiva e na circulação sanguínea
adequada a vitamina B12 é encontrada
basicamente em alimentos de origem
animal como é o caso de carne bovina
fígado Cordeiro frango peixes ovos e
laticínios então você pode estar
pensando por que estou com B12 baixa
claro que uma das razões é a falta do
consumo desses alimentos mas não é o
único problema e talvez nem seja o maior
Porque isso pode acontecer em pessoas
vegetarianas que T um consumo reduzido
mas existem muitas pessoas que consomem
esses alimentos com frequência e mesmo
assim tem níveis baixos de B12 Qual que
é o mistério as causas além da dieta
podem ser desde dificuldade de absorção
porque a vitamina B12 precisa ser
separada da proteína para ser absorvida
para essa separação acontecer é muito
importante que a gente tenha Uma acidez
adequada no estômago que é um PH ácido
muitas pessoas simplesmente não t esse
ácido estomacal suficiente para fazer
essa separação da B12 da proteína Isso é
uma condição conhecida como
hipocloridria então baixo nível de acio
no estômago é uma das causas pessoas que
consomem álcool de forma regular ou em
excesso também estão em risco já que o
álcool afeta o fígado onde a B2 é
armazenada Além disso doenças autoimunes
como a doença de crom a doença celíaca
podem interferir na absorção de B12
atenção aos consumidores excessivos de
café aqueles que bebem mais de quatro ou
5 xícaras por dia vocês também podem ter
níveis baixos de B12 pacientes que
fizeram cirurgia de redução de estômago
pessoas que estão com infecção por h
pilor o cibo alguns tipos de gastrite
como a gastrite atrófica pessoas que
tomam muitos antiácidos estão todos em
risco de deficiência medicamentos como a
metiformina usado para controlar o
açúcar do sangue inibidores de bomba de
próton os famosos prazois como é o caso
do mi prazol podem interferir
significativamente na absorção de B1 o
uso prolongado desses prazois pode
aumentar o risco de deficiência de B1 em
até
65% agora vamos focar na suplementação a
vitamina B12 pode pode ser suplementado
de várias formas diferentes via
intramuscular ou seja inão no músculo
intravenosa dentro da veia oral ou
sublingual a escolha da via de
suplementação vai depender das suas
necessidades individuais e da orientação
do seu profissional de saúde por exemplo
a suplementação intramuscular ou
intravenosa pode ser utilizada para
garantir uma absorção mais rápida e efic
especialmente em pessoas que têm
deficiência Severa ou em situações onde
absorção oral está bem comprometida eu
especialmente prefiro as formas
sublingual ou intramuscular e
intravenosa você já deve ter ouvido
falar principalmente sobre a
cianocobalamina que é a forma mais comum
a forma sintética da B12 e também da
metilcobalamina que é a formativa
natural da B12 Talvez não tenha ouvido
falar sobre a
hidroxicalciferol mesmo patamar que
metilcobalamina pois ambas existem em
formas ativas que podem ser utilizadas
diretamente pelo nosso organismo O
problema é que a adenosilcobalamina não
é facilmente encontrada para suplementar
aqui no Brasil já hidroxi balamina é a
mais comum encontrada nos alimentos ela
também uma forma natural de vitamina B12
também pode ser facilmente convertida
pelo corpo em uma das outras formas
ativas para vocês entenderem melhor a
hidroxicalciferol
linguais algumas Farmácias de
Manipulação ou magistrais já trabalham
com ela e eu mesmo prescrevo essa forma
para alguns pacientes isso quando
necessário e um ponto muito interessante
sobre ela é que em caso de intoxicação
por cianeto como por exposição a fumaças
de incêndio ou materiais plásticos a
hidroxicalciferol a cianocobalamina que
é eliminada pela urina e a
cianocobalamina ela é a forma mais
conhecida mais antiga está no mercado a
muito tempo ela é amplamente disponível
em farmácias e é a forma usada em
medicamentos como é o caso do citoneurin
no entanto essa forma de vitamina B2 é
sintética e requer várias etapas de
metabolização no corpo antes de se
transformar nas formas que nós queremos
as formas ativas que são a
metilcobalamina e a Zil cobalamina só
assim ela pode ser efetivamente
utilizada pelo
organismo então pra maioria das pessoas
essa conversão esses processos não
representam problema mas algumas pessoas
podem ter dificuldades especialmente
aquelas que têm alguma alteração
genética uma mutação ou pessoas que TM
doenças autoimunes problemas digestório
ou hepáticos além de deficiência de
outros nutrientes importantes então a
cianocobalamina contém uma molécula de
cianeto que é uma substância que como
vocês provavelmente já sabem é venenosa
do ponto de vista toxicológico essa
quantidade de suplemento é considerada
insignificante mas o corpo ainda Precisa
removê-la o que envolve o sistema de
detox utilizando substâncias como a
glutationa o problema pessoal é que esse
processo pode sobrecarregar o organismo
de pessoas que já TM histórico de
intoxicação inflamação ou doenças
hepáticas doenças do fígado nesses casos
mesmo pequena quantidade de cianeto pode
ser problemático mas a cianocobalamina
ainda é uma boa opção para muitas
pessoas ela é mais antiga muito barata é
de fácil acesso e pode elevar os níveis
de B12 de forma eficaz pra maioria das
pessoas e tem uma alta estabilidade
também isso vai manter os níveis ótimos
por um tempo relativamente prolongado
mesmo após suspensão do uso portanto
apesar dos cuidados necessários não
devemos condenar totalmente o uso da
cianocobalamina
bem agora vamos falar sobre a
metilcobalamina que é a forma ativa e
natural mais conhecida da B12 Existem
algumas polêmicas na área médica sobre
ela alguns cientistas e médicos afirmam
que ela pode ter menor afinidade para
criar estoques de B2 no corpo na maioria
dos pacientes quando se utiliza a
metilcobalamina e se suspende o uso por
qualquer qualquer motivo os níveis no
sangue os níveis séricos de bed tendem a
cair mais rapidamente do que com outras
opções como ancian com balamina que tem
uma estabilidade maior após a utilização
outro problema frequentemente mencionado
é que a metilcobalamina é menos estável
e suscetível a fotodecomposição isso
significa o qu que ela é mais facilmente
destruída pela exposição à luz então se
você comprar um suplemento de
metilcobalamina é importante armazená-lo
adequadamente longe da luz solar local
escuro não pode ter exposição direta à
luz solar ou calor e preste atenção à
validade se for um suplemento manipulado
é essencial que seja feito numa maf
massa magistral idônea mas é importante
lembrar que a metilcobalamina é uma das
melhores formas de B2 disponíveis e é a
que eu mais prescrevo e vejo resultados
ela é mais eficiente na captação por
organelas de neurônios o que significa
que ela pode fornecer melhores
resultados para distúrbio o sistema
nervoso como é o caso da epilepsia aos
rimer esclerose múltipla outras
condições Além disso pessoas com
polimorfismos genéticos que afeta o
metabolismo da vitamina B12 essas
pessoas podem se beneficiar muito dessa
forma ativa de B12 a metilcobalamina
juntamente com a adenosilcobalamina
podem ser excelentes alternativas nesses
casos Especialmente quando combinados
com outro outras vitaminas como B6 B9 e
Colina pessoal avaliar com um bom
profissional de saúde é fundamental para
entender Qual é a melhor forma e dose
pro seu caso além de combinar com outras
vitaminas e suplementos isso conforme
necessário também é importante entender
porque você está com níveis baixos de B2
e corrigir essa causa isso pode evitar a
necessidade de suplementação constante E
permitir que você mantenha bons de
estoque de B12 por mais tempo no entanto
em alguns casos a suplementação regular
pode ser necessária compartilhe os
vídeos bem a vida de além pode Mud
[Música]
tamb Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
você é pera